today I'm going to be speaking with
Professor Alistair Smith who teaches
politics at New York University and is
also co-author of the book The
dictator's handbook why bad behavior is
almost always good politics I really
appreciate your time uh great to have
you on today
very glad to be here
so let's start with this this premise
that bad behavior is good politics
because it seems maybe to to the
layperson that sometimes bad behavior is
actually bad politics but it seems that
maybe more internationally and less So
within the country wherein that is
taking place so is it important to
distinguish when we say bad behavior is
good politics whether we're talking
about International reaction or within a
Leader's country or does it does it not
matter does the principle hold true
regardless
well I think we should stop worrying
about what's good or bad we should worry
about what leaders choose to do and what
leaders to do is what's good for them I
want to emphasize them as the particular
individual and not the country so the
president United States does what is
good for the president United States Kim
Jong-un does what is good for Kim
Jong-un and that typically means keeping
those people happy that you need to stay
in power the difference between why we
get much better governance in the United
States is because the U.S president
needs the support of tens of millions of
people and Kim Jong-un needs the support
of tens or hundreds but certainly no
more than thousands of people and it's
that scale of how do you keep a lot the
the appropriate people happy determines
the kinds of policies that leaders have
that's interesting so in the United
States the good politics are that which
will get you re-elected in the system we
have which includes a hundred plus
million people voting obviously with the
influence of lobbies and corporations
and all of these other things in North
Korea similarly the good politics that
keep you in power are those immediately
sort of around you who could try to
depose you but it is less about the
population of North Korea
right you should never make the mistake
of thinking leaders are out there to
make life good for the people and so the
US I don't think of the us as behaving
in a very particularly normatively good
way with respect to overseas politics
which is I think where you where you
started this conversation is because the
U.S president is not beholden to the
people in other countries so the U at
the president's job is to enrich and
improve the welfare of the people that
he needs to stay in power and we
shouldn't expect him to do anything else
so foreign aid military intervention is
designed for promoting the interests of
the people the president cares about and
not the interests of the countries where
AID is being delivered or intervention
is taking place if we look at a
situation like Russia which is being
sanctioned heavily because of its
incursion into Ukraine
um there was an interesting NPR piece I
heard about a week ago which argued that
despite whatever is being publicly said
about the very limited impact of the
sanctions the sanctions are actually
really disastrous for Russia at all
levels I guess we don't know
definitively whether that's true or not
but let's let's imagine that it is the
case that the sanctions are having a
disastrous impact how does that change
or impact this balance of what is good
to stay in power when you introduce an
external Force like a sanction
well you know again why sanctions I
always think of whenever sanctions are
applied they've almost always failed
before they start if if the sanction was
going to be a big enough stick that it
was going to get compliance
that the leader in the in the Target
state would have already complied with
the threat so the fact that they're
being applied means that they're almost
certainly not going to work
and why do they get applied it's because
it's domestically popular for Western
Europe and North America to apply these
sanctions so it's good for the president
to do it keeping the constituents happy
it prop it may actually be very helpful
in in Russia uh one one of the crisis
one of the consequences the price of oil
is higher so there's more Revenue also
the fact that there's now limited
options for the oligarchs or um to trade
and enrich themselves in any other way
all the revenue all the wealth all the
benefits that are coming politically now
come centrally through Putin because the
sanctions have limited the access and so
in some sense it's given Putin a little
bit more power this is our problem with
sanctions you know uh in when the U.S
sanctioned Iraq against Saddam Hussein
one of the consequences was that the the
value of smuggling became much more
valuable who controlled the smuggling
the cronies of Saddam Hussein who became
massively wealthy because the the
population suffered as a whole if we if
we stick specifically with dictatorships
and sort of pseudo dictatorships with
authoritarians strong men and and those
types of countries
what are the most effective strategies
for weakening a dictator's Coalition of
supporters like we talked about that the
general population can take what works
what doesn't work
well the the real problem is dictitors
once they are well established in power
they're very very hard to bring down
so we you need to look for moments of
weakness in bringing about change and we
should recognize that we can't just
bring down dictators because we feel
like getting rid of them you know I
think most people in the United States
would like to see the North Korean
regime replace but that's just wishful
thinking unless the US is willing to
invade which I think would be a very
poor policy just expecting that the
people are going to rise up and bring it
bring the regime down because it's a
terrible regime is not going to happen
right so you need to look for moments of
weakness in regimes and in in autocratic
regimes such as North Korea that the
times of actually much more likely to be
health related than any other reason
economic leaders can survive terrible
economic crises we can think of you know
the sanctions in Iraq uh Saddam Hussein
survived those it took U.S military
intervention to remove him we could look
at the Venezuela the Maduro seems to
have held on to power the economy's
being driven into the ground but he made
sure that he paid just the right number
of people just the right amount so they
stayed loyal so the military are well
fed
um and and he survived in Powers it's it
we can't just give instructions to the
people and say this is going to happen
you need to that we should accept that
these regimes are going to survive in
power when we look at um instances in
history where a regime has fallen uh
what are some of the most notable
examples that were not health related
that come to mind
or are there any notables that come to
mind well you know
failure to pay people the right amount
of money and
um harming the interests of those who
keep you in power so you know the
Russians are in World War One
uh he had this crazy
um tax he used to tax vodka but because
he didn't want the truth being drunk
he's sort of banned vodka during World
War one that cut off a huge amount of
Revenue cut down on the amount of money
you had to pay people then what did he
do he turned around and told the
soldiers that were guarding him at the
Winter Palace they were going to get
sent to the front line to fight to fight
the Germans well they didn't want to go
fight the Germans at the front line and
what did they do they opened the gates
and allowed the people to come in and so
the revolution succeeded
generally leaders are deposed because
the people around them allow the masses
to succeed or or they take care of it
and Accu themselves it's very rare that
the people will succeed
um and so that's the case where it's
quite simply the Russians are didn't pay
the right people uh didn't reward them
properly and they turned on him
um the classic case I like to think of
is Julius Caesar so Julius Caesar we
think of as you know if we follow our
Shakespeare we think of him as trying to
be a tyrant well he was already he was
already the dictator he was already
effectively the the king
um the problem for him was he actually
tried to enrich the people
um there was huge debts from the wars
that have been incurred and meant that a
lot of regular Roman citizens were being
sold into slavery because they couldn't
settle their debts and he tried to
alleviate this debt burden unfortunately
the people who own the debt were the
Senators around him so when he tried to
get rid of the debt he tried to help the
people and look what it got him he got
him stabbed by by his fellows in the
Senate
if we go from the autocratic
circumstances and dictators to
democracies one of the features or bugs
depending on your perspective about
democracies uh capitalist democracies
Western democracies is that
um the very nature of the economic
circumstances of large swaths of people
we can think about the United States in
this case is that they are
overwhelmingly in a position where they
can't afford to coalesce and take the
actions that might be most impactful in
in the sense of well Mass rallies at
Urban centers and not going into work
for a month and so on and trying to
the financial system these are
things which we can all imagine having
an impact on the country and at least
having the potential to achieve some
change but because Healthcare is mostly
tied to employment and because 40
percent of the population can't meet an
unexpected 400 expense the system itself
creates a population that will find it
more difficult to activate in a way that
is more likely to achieve change can you
talk a little bit do you agree with that
analysis can you talk a little bit about
whether that does become its own
impediment to activism
well I I think I I actually sort of a
little bit disagree there okay most
Americans don't want to bring down the
American system of government is the
American system of government is
incredibly representative and the
government by and large generates huge
numbers of public goods uh a safe
environment Law and Order transparent
government uh National Defense
um or all these Public Health these
things are provided and these are
precisely the things people want so we
protest because we would like the
government to work harder but we
actually have a system of government
that we actually like the very few
people seem to want to I mean Trump's
attempt to take over the government the
um yeah
um the relatively few there was
thousands of people who thought that was
a good idea the vast majority of the
people did not show up because they like
the institutions that we have
um you were discussing the inability to
coordinate it's the it's the people who
really want political change who don't
have the ability you and I we have the
right to free speech we can say what we
like we can meet with our friends we can
go where we like we can publish we can
talk we can speak people in North Korea
don't have those freedoms they have a
terrible form of government yes they
live in an abject poverty they're not
allowed to go anywhere they're not
allowed to say anything
um economically they're terribly off
they would love to change their system
of government but they don't have the
ability to in the United States we have
the ability to protest we just you know
the systems the system isn't group isn't
isn't perfect but we shouldn't strive
for Perfection the system is good and
therefore most of the time we don't want
to bring it down well I guess it's
interesting to think about it with
something like for example health care
and when you look at polling about
health care the polling seems pretty
clear that even across the political
Spectrum
people generally believe that the
government should provide some basic
level of care regardless of ability to
pay not everybody supports Medicare for
all very clearly and the more
information you give about Medicare for
all support actually goes down a little
bit but some minimum level of care that
would be something that you would think
is okay we we have a functioning
superstructure but this is a pretty big
program that we would like to see
function differently it doesn't happen
and different people point to different
things well the amount of influence that
the health insurance Lobby has or the
Republican politicians don't want it or
there's too much money to be made for
the doctors under the system we have or
whatever the case may be how would the
type of analysis you do look at
something that is a pretty clear desire
from the people but that doesn't seem to
be getting any closer
well we we should remember that the U.S
whilst it's a good system isn't perfect
and winning winning a seat in Congress
doesn't require like half the voters in
your District first of all the districts
are highly gerrymandered yes many of
them are and so often you just need to
win the primary well we're in the
primary you can often win with five or
ten percent of the votes in the in the
primary so we're really now thinking
that to win a seat to get representation
we're looking at let's say 10 of the
population in of the voting population
in the district well that's much smaller
than thinking about the half that we
tend to think of as Democratic right and
and so if we want to produce changes
that are going to produce more what I
always call public goods things that
benefit everybody good Public Health
Care National Defense things like that
then we want to always work to increase
the number of people to whom politicians
of aholden so you know to win the
presidency and clean up the house and
Senate you only win you need 25 million
votes is enough if you put them in the
right seats because it's not it's it's
first past the post and the seats are
extremely dis unevenly distributed
um and we got the Electoral College so
you don't need you know you sit there I
think it was 360 million people on in
the US so you know let's say there's 200
million so if you need 100 million
voters but you need a quarter of that
because not everybody votes and things
are disproportionately set up so the way
from my perspective the way to think
about improving public policy is to make
leaders accountable to more people the
more people they're interested in the
the smaller the impact of specialist
lobbies like doctors uh Healthcare
lobbyists healthcare insurance companies
um if if you've got to buy you know if
you've got to buy a thousand votes
you're going to listen to them a lot if
you've got to buy a million votes you're
going to listen to them less and so so
to me that is always the the solution to
this is not legislative or anything like
that it's changing the institutions by
which governments operate and I'm trying
to think through the math of like the
congressional district so if you've got
a very lopsided congressional district
let's just call it that there's 750 000
people per congressional district
although it I think it varies a little
bit but let's say it's 7 50.
um if voter turnout in the general is 50
uh but not everybody is even eligible
you're talking about a couple of hundred
thousand total votes but then the
primary might only be a fraction of one
party so you're down to 80 to 100 000
and if only 20 come out that's 20 000
votes and you need 51 of that to win the
primary you're talking about like 12 000
votes might win you a congressional
primary and that might be all there is
to it that's exactly that's exactly the
kind of maths how I like to think about
political systems I don't like to think
of them as in some nominal terms of
democracy accuracy or autocracy or
whatever I like to think of them in
exactly that that's exactly the kind of
calculation I like to think about
classifying political regime so let's
think about how we can change those
things like there are so loser laws so
if you lose a primary yes you can't run
in the general elections in Six States
right I don't think that that is
everywhere no they vary the rules
because the elect of the Constitution
says the Electoral rules are set by the
by the states but in a lot of places you
can't run again it makes it very hard
um for a Centrist candidate that might
appeal broadly to actually get through
the primary and then run in the general
election so yeah these These are the
kind of changes that I think are useful
for getting implementing Health Care
the book is the dictator's handbook why
bad behavior is almost always good
politics and we've been speaking with
the book's co-author Professor Alastair
Smith from New York University so
appreciate your time and your insights
today
very good very glad to spend some time
with you